it has now been a whole year since
circa's casino opening and you might
remember it took a risk and it opened
amid the pandemic while business looks
good 8 news now reporter sally jaramillo
spoke to economist david schwartz and
also people who visit the area she
brings us more on how circa is doing and
what it's bringing to the downtown las
vegas area sally
denise many people i spoke to today say
it's thanks to casinos like circa that
are helping make the area more beautiful
cleaner and be safer but it's also the
number one reason why many tourists and
locals keep coming back when circa
opened there was a lot of uncertainty
about what the future held for downtown
las vegas gaming historian and professor
at unlv david schwartz says it's been
proven that the demand was there and
opening up was a good idea evens looking
at their parking garage the garage mahal
i think totally
transformed what transportation to
downtown las vegas is like for some
people schwartz says once people are in
downtown las vegas they like what they
see not just at circa but everywhere
else it's not at all surprising to me
that a year after opening they're going
strong they've got a wonderful facility
semionite erev is from hawaii and visits
three times a year she loves to gamble
and says thanks to serka she feels more
comfortable doing so a lot of
improvement it's clean we cannot get in
without an id it's sick rachel wisner is
from michigan she also visits more than
once a year and says she loves the many
slots you can find at circa as well as
the little pieces of history it's cool
you get a lot of service in there
and that's kind of hard to come by
especially right now wesner is a
business owner and applaud circa for the
commitment especially during such
challenging times i think what you've
seen with circa is an outgrowth of a
trend that was that started even before
the pandemic where downtown las vegas's
gaming revenue number growth was
outperforming the strip just in the
percentage of increase
out here live schwartz says resorts
world is another example and he believes
these two properties have helped put us
on a path where they will be more
development in the coming years salihara
live local now